[Music]
today is Wednesday February 15 1995 and
we're talking with Charles Wyckoff about
his work with Harold Edgerton by way of
introduction could you tell us about how
you came to MIT and got into Doc's lab
and tell us your story from the
beginning okay there is a beginning the
I I went to Dartmouth College and I
figured that I need a needed a little
more technical experience so I came down
to MIT and a friend of mine had already
preceded me and he knew of Doc and he
came around to me one day and he said he
knew that I was interested in color
photography I'd already had a patent
pending on that and so he said I think
doc would be interested in having you
part of the scene so he introduced me to
Doc and it looked very interesting so in
1939 in conjunction with my studies here
I started to fiddle around with Doc in
the lab and helped him out here and
there and that's how I I finally got
hooked on Doc because as everybody knows
he's kind of a magic character he's got
a he's got a very inviting personality
and that makes you want to work with him
the first thing he did was to show me
some of the experiments he was working
on and they were exactly what I had in
mind so from that day on I was hooked it
was the first big project that you
worked on the nighttime aerial
reconnaissance photography that didn't
come until later the the first big
project really was connected with a navy
we dock and I would go down to the del
gran proving ground the Navy proving
ground and then we'd alternating go to
the army proving ground at Aberdeen and
we would take the microfibre long
and a couple of cameras and photograph
bullets going through the air just
before they impacted a steel target and
this was of course before the before the
war now an interesting episode there by
the way occurred at Aberdeen we had a
big bomb up on a pole I forgotten what
it was maybe ten thousand pounds or
something like that the biggest one that
they had exploded so far well he hadn't
exploded it yet they were getting ready
to and it was full of instruments and
doc and I had a camera called the
Jenkins camera it was one that he got
from the widow of C Francis Jenkins and
he dug it out of the museum
not this museum because this museum
hadn't started yet and we conditioned
that camera so that we could take
pictures and it was we used a a bent
piece of metal from the USS Kearsarge
Howe as our as our shelter so the camera
would be inside this shelter by means of
a mirror it would look at the bomb over
here and and we had selected they we
didn't select the sight but somebody at
Aberdeen had selected this sight as
being a perfect sight because it was in
the middle of an artillery range and
nobody would come around and and you
know be too near the bomb when I went
off so we were just about finished with
our preparation just about ready to
start the tests and we were going to
leave when all of a sudden we heard
bullets coming over and they landed
fairly close to us so everybody
scrambled to get out of there
and doc was out taking pictures at the
time so he calmly folded up his camera
and I stayed behind in here and he doc
was out in the front I said what are you
doing out there and he said well the
bullets are coming from here Charlie
you're going to get hit and I said the
bomb was over there doc if it goes off
you're gonna get hit so hard to get back
and forth we finally settled if they can
went into went into safety immediately
so so that was my interesting to care my
introduction to kind of hair braiding
things that happened to us from that on
and the adapted Jenkins camera was a
motion picture that was a motion picture
camera 35 millimeter I'd used nitrate
film because that's all there was in
those early days and of course that's a
an explosive hazard in itself
the camera would operate it was built in
1916 by the way and this camera would
operate had 3,000 pictures per second
and about every third or fourth time he
operated it would jam and burst into
flames that meant that we had to take it
had 48 lenses in it that meant that I
had to take it all apart clean each lens
out and put it back together again okay
so how did how did that work of blowing
things up and photographing it translate
through your career because I know this
is a common theme while it is ending up
with a Bob's tell us about the path from
well alright let's get down to dog run
for a moment because this is almost an
introduction now to a bombs there were
two officers down there two naval
officers in connection with us testing
we were doing on bullets one of them was
a man by the name of Norris Bradbury who
ultimately went out to Los Alamos in the
Manhattan Project and he became the
director of the Los Alamos lab we met
him down there another one was Admiral
Parsons he was a commander at that time
and he became the chief weapon heir for
the Japanese bombs so we didn't know
that that's what we're going to happen
but that's some of our experience that
to Dahlgren the navy proving ground and
then the war was beginning to show up we
still weren't in the war but Colonel
Goddard got a hold of doc and wanted
something to replace flash bombs
and so doc started working on the the
electronic flash for airplane use and we
were all all involved in that project
for a while this the war still hadn't
started and as I would explain it to you
earlier one of the ways we would test
this thing would be to have airplanes
fly out of Logan at different altitudes
and then we'd photograph these planes so
that we would know how far away we could
photograph in other words what altitude
we had to fly in order to get a good
picture on the ground and we were able
to do this with I hate to say it but
Doc's brashness and calling up a pilot
and say would you fly over from MIT for
so certain altitude and that's how he
does it then later on the the Navy now
we got into the war and the Navy was
calling and doc said Charlie you take
the Navy stuff and I'm going to work on
this stuff for the Army Air Corps and so
we kind of split at that time I handled
all the Navy stuff and talked handle the
airforce stuff along with fret large
difference what's that what was the
difference was it the same equipment
just the two forces or was there a
difference because I don't know there's
the Navy used and what the arm here well
there was quite a bit of difference
because the army was interested in this
the Army Air Corps was interested in the
in the electronic flash from the air
mm-hmm and that was a different thing
altogether the the dorito flash duration
didn't have to be as short as it did for
taking pictures of bullets or shockwaves
so this was just a matter of doc putting
together all kinds of capacitance to
really pump a lot of electronics into
the flash tube and so that kept him busy
just working on that whereas my stuff
with the Navy was just the standard
micro flash and things like that so your
work continued out of what you were
doing at Dahlgren that's right
continuation a bullet in artillery yes
and then we went in Washington there was
a place called the model Basin which is
again
run by the Navy they had a water tank
and they would explode little charges
underwater and I would take high-speed
motion pictures of it now this was
simulating what a mine or a torpedo
would do underwater mm-hmm and every now
and then dock would come down and see
what was happening and he'd offer his
advice this is the way we got going who
else worked with you on this from from
Doc's immediate circle I know Fred
Barstow was for love but with he with
the electric flash you know well yes
it's an electronic flash in each case
right sorry I meant but he he
concentrated with with doc on the aerial
stuff whereas I yes now swig of water I
think I will because I'm getting a
little now Fred started out by the way
doing a thesis under doc and this was an
interesting story he was studying shock
wave propagation in glass and
crystalline things and he had a lab up
on the second floor building Tim and not
a lab he had an office there and he had
shattered glass all over the floor the
custodians were afraid to go in there so
he had to do his old cleaning now the
interesting part of that story is not
the glass on the floor but he decided
that he was going to study this same
phenomenon with with sugar with with
crystals of sugar so he got a hold of
some Kanyon candy manufacturer who gave
him all sorts of samples of sugar and
plate form and whenever I'd come in to
visit him we'd start eating up his
samples so I got of the time you really
wanted to be didn't have any samples
left he had to send for some more but so
that's how Fred got started with with
Doc
and he was more interested in the
electronics and so he helped Doc and Ken
dermis house and put the electronics
together for the aerial photography
group and so during the war
although doc went abroad and Fred stated
in the lab here at MIT he was he was
part of Doc's team on that whereas I was
strictly Navy now you said that you
originally came to MIT because of your
interest in color photography no no
because I realized I needed some
technical education which I only got a
moderate amount of it that Dartmouth I
happen to be interested in pan color
photography and that's that's really how
I got associated with Doc because this
friend of mine
I haven't pancake thought that I might
be able to add something to doc in other
words doc was interested in color at
that time so perhaps my background might
have been a little more suitable than
most people and especially since I was
interested in photography knew darkroom
technology and all this looked like a
good good partnership which it turned
out to be so does that mean that when
doc started developing the Cota Tron for
studio work and he used that for some
early color photography in the studio
you were part of that yes well that's
right can you talk a little bit about
sure the in the early days we did all
the glassblowing right in the lab at MIT
so all the tubes were made right there
and the gas filling these tubes in the
early days in the very early days was
strictly hydrogen and then mercury and
of course these were not very good as
lady emitters and then along came
Krypton and that was much better and so
the the studio units started out with
Krypton but they were deficient in
certain colors so it was very difficult
to get a good color picture using a
Krypton too
and I don't know what doc did but he got
ahold of somebody at the General
Electric plant in Cleveland Neela Park
who was interested in and the exotic
gases the rare gases and so this fella
showed up one day and in our office at
MIT with a flask and they said here is
the world's largest supply of xenon gas
right here and so we started filling the
tubes with that and I made some
spectrogram showing what the light
output of that was contrasted with
Krypton and it looked perfect it looks
just like sunlight so we started using
that in our in our so-called studio
units the Kota Tron units and that made
colour photography with electronic flash
much more practical than it had been
although color pictures were made before
that why was Xena so hard to come by I
didn't have any any use and here it is
floating around in the atmosphere but
where is our gun I forgot to mention our
gun our gun came along before Krypton
and argon of course was in use long
before Krypton was and it's used for the
welding industry so there was an
abundant supply of argon and then
Krypton began to be used for the same
thing so there was a more abundant
supply that but nobody want nobody
wanted xenon they didn't even know about
it so this fellow from GE managed to
somehow or another find out how to
collect it and bake it and that's how we
got started we didn't want it we didn't
want to tell him right away that's what
we're going to use because we didn't
have any to test out right in order to
make a spectrogram to see what it would
be like but it was it was a perfect
simulation of sunlight
okay so the war you've gone through the
war you've photographed all these
bullets you're getting into well we
haven't really gone through the warrior
dog some of these things happen during
that time and some of them occurred
before that time and some of them
occurred after that time but now let's
let's get after the war okay
the since the war was really over and
the a bombs had already three of them
had already been exploded one of them in
Alamogordo New Mexico two of them over
Japan and the fourth one was going to be
a navy test out of bikini
and so since I had established myself
for the Navy connection it was obvious
that these Navy people wanted me to be
involved in that so I got involved from
the standpoint of edgerton germeshausen
and grier that's what the partnership
was called at that time I was I was a
navy representative from each from
edgerton germeshausen and grier on that
test and that was probably the world's
largest fiasco I don't think they'll
ever be another one as big as that why
everything went wrong everything you can
think of this was a big show the Navy
said there's no there's no bomb that's
gonna sink our ships you know so we'll
get him out in force and we'll test them
and we'll find out and the the Air Force
of course hadn't been the earth hadn't
come into being as an Air Force it was
still the US Army Air Corps and they
were the ones that were going to drop
the bomb on the target ship the target
ship in that case was the Nevada which
was a victim at Pearl Harbor but they
salvaged it and reconditioned it and it
served its its its duty during World War
two
and then afterwards they said let's use
that ship as our target ship so they
painted it a bright orange color because
that's supposed to signify danger they
knew that red would be darker so they
picked orange but it turned out that
orange was a bad color too because from
20 or 30 miles it blended it into the
ocean you couldn't see it
so the the bombing people just couldn't
see it so they had 36 inch arc
searchlights
aimed right down that bombing alley and
the Bombardier still couldn't see it
until they got within about 15 miles and
that's too close they couldn't alter
their course and so I heard about this
and I just had one of the pieces of
equipment that I had with me you know
what I want all been on this thing I
didn't know what I was gonna be faced
with so I took all the equipment I could
think of that we might use one of them
was a unit that we call a sea search
unit this was something that was that we
developed during the war to fly at
fairly low altitudes looking for
submarines and when we see something
that we'd flash me get a picture of it
and that looked like a unit that I might
use somewhere on this test so I brought
it along we'll have a slight break here
and incidentally during all this
decision-making that the with the carbon
arc searchlight they said this is the
wrong color of the ship so let's paint
it white so all the superstructure was
painted white and the white paint didn't
dry right away so here the whole walk
around it white feet that made a mess
and I had lunch with the skipper of the
ship one day and of course I dragged my
white painted shoes hunt it was a nice
carpet and he had a piano in his office
I said what's the piano for he said well
you know I like to play the piano so I
brought it along so were you gonna lose
it he said I'm gonna sail this ship back
to Pearl Harbor so he said I'll tell you
something right now this ship was not
seaworthy I had all the pumps going full
blast in order to keep it afloat to get
out here he said but I'm gonna sail it
back to Pearl Harbor after the test well
he was right he did
anyhow the I tried this he searched unit
out I mounted the thing up on the mast
right beside the 36 inch carbon
searchlights and it was radio control so
that the Bombardier could flash it
anytime he wanted so when he got to a
position where he said let me see if I
can see it he would wash it and he found
that he could see this thing from 40
miles out as opposed to 15 so that was a
very useful thing so you might say that
this should have made everything perfect
well it helped but not quite enough the
this was the very first large-scale test
where telemetry was was being used for
the first time now telemetry is means
really that year
you're gonna radio out your signals to a
remote spot so they don't get damaged
and since this was a navy show the Navy
selected their smartest statisticians
and decided where the antenna should be
to you know to transmit the data and
where do you think point actually turned
out to be honey or the antenna so that
was one thing that was bad
another thing that was bad was that the
the Army Air Corps fellows said that we
can hit a pickle barrel from 20,000 feet
so we'll have no trouble dropping the
bomb right on the Nevada well the
trouble is there was no pickle barrel
the the Bombardier was was not given
access to this bomb until the last
minute and the casing was not what he
was told it was and it turned out that
the casing was not air worthy so as the
bomb was released the tail bent he
didn't pull off but it bent and so it
didn't go down the way it was supposed
to go down so it landed a half mile off
target that's why I led it on the on the
antennas so the Nevada was saved
and now another thing that happened the
Manhattan district had been disband
there wasn't anymore and so Los Alamos
was kind of on their own there was no
Atomic Energy Commission yet and they
were the ones that supplied the timing
signals out to each person who was doing
an experiment and I had some I had some
high-speed motion picture cameras out
there and the total recording time the
total time on and off before he ran out
of film was two seconds well the the
zero time didn't come along until
seventeen seconds after the explosion so
obviously I didn't get any records it
was all wiped out right there but I did
have some other instruments that were
self-supporting they were operating by a
photocell so I did get those records so
everywhere the the zero the the nobody
that really needed precise timing got
any data because the timing signals
didn't go off and all the reporters the
news photographers the newspapers the
magazine reporters radio they any we
talked with army bikini was such a nice
place that they you know they liked it
on the beach and they wrote all their
stories the day beforehand and they said
well all we have to do is ship them out
and that's it well watch the thing well
of course it didn't work the way their
story said so there was a mad scramble
to try to get the stories back and then
write it the way it should of it now you
can see where I says the world's largest
fiasco it really well we had Russian
visitors out there and everybody was
open to the public almost so from then
on the security was a lot more tight
yeah we were able to do things that so
tell us about the development of the
rabbit rhotic and and and some were
successful all right the very first
official job that incidentally EG&G was
still edges in German sales and Greer
and we had our offices right here at MIT
and we had to have our own guards you
know for security and the very first
test that that we went on officially not
not the bikini test officially from
edgerton germeshausen and grier was in
1947 or 48 called sandstone and we were
not doing photography on that test we
were doing photocell work with silica
sillas copes and things like that and it
was strictly a shipboard operation we
weren't in the we weren't in the on land
and so during the during the time no I
beg your pardon we did have some
stations on land we had some big
reflectors with Florida cells in them
and they were telemetered out to worship
anyhow during the waiting period we got
to talking with some of the guests out
there and it turned out these guests
that we were talking with were what you
might call embryo Atomic Energy
commissioners they were about to form
but they hadn't formed yet and the
Wright Patterson was doing the
high-speed photography and we told them
we thought that was the wrong approach
even though that's basically what we did
high-speed motion pictures we said
that's the wrong approach and we said in
doc said particularly what we need are
some large pictures you know single
pictures well can you do that doc says
sure we didn't have the camera to do it
yet but you know he knew we could come
up with something somewhere so we went
back and incidentally on the basis of
that not that alone but on the basis of
that we did get the contract with the
AEC we were their first prime contractor
not because of that but because of the
timing and firing and this this kind of
help so we put on a full glass program
to try to develop a camera which would
take a single picture you know maybe two
or three inches of square
in a very short time and one of them was
a was a camera called a from Eastman
Kodak called a multiple aperture focal
plane scanner that's a mouthful it was
somewhat similar to one of the early TV
systems back in 1916 called the nip card
disc but not quite the same then we had
another one in which we used a crystal
with polarized polarisers ammonium
dihydrogen phosphate crystal and I
worked on that one and I also worked on
the the Eastman camera and incidentally
that's how I got into the film business
because the film required for that
camera was non-existent so the camera
didn't work we paid we got three cameras
paid $100,000 for each and the cameras
wouldn't work because the film was wrong
so I got into the film business at that
stage came up with an emulsion working
with Kodak that made it work and the
ammonium dihydrogen phosphate shutter
wasn't working out doc in the meantime
was working on one called
the ferret each other and it got down to
the point in our program where we had to
cut out something and concentrate on one
and we'd already committed ourselves for
the Eastman camera so that was a goal so
the other one to cut out was the one I
was working on because it just wasn't
producing results so I jumped with Doc
and we worked on the on the magneto
shutter and that's the beginning of the
rabbit Roenick right there we finally
got that up to the point where that
would work but we were hamstrung because
in those days the we knew we had to use
polarized light and and in order to make
it work with a fairly principle you have
a a lead glass cylinder with a wire
wrapped around a coil and if you
discharge the capacitor through that
coil it creates a magnetic field for a
very short time and that actually
rotates the plane of polarization
nothing mechanically move was they just
rotates the plane of polarization and it
lets the
like through but using a puller or two
polarizers together when you cross them
it doesn't produce enough density it
produces enough density so that you know
you could use them as goggles to watch
an a-bomb but not enough to exclude
light the way we we had to so I came up
with the idea of using two systems one
of them with a cylinder and the cross
polarizers and a third one behind or a
second one behind it and so we we tried
to get Polaroid to make this for us and
land inland said well that isn't gonna
work you know you you get infinite
density of nickle prisms and I said well
we're not using nickel prisons so the
thing that makes this work is the fact
that you've got a polarizer system here
and the light leakage that comes out is
still plane polarized therefore you can
use it oh yes he said that's right now
he didn't agree to this right away I had
to bring the whole team over I had to
bring doc I had to bring Ken derm asylum
I had to bring Bob Morris Bob Davis and
there was an array of us maybe if a half
a dozen sitting in his office trying to
convince him it would work so that he
ought to make it for us
he said that's fine I agree but how are
we gonna know that we're lined up we
don't have a photocell a little work
I said well doc said we do because we've
just been working on something similar
to that so we'll give you a photocell
system to tell you when they're when
they're properly oriented so that's that
was the beginning of the rabbit Roenick
right there but we still knew that that
wasn't enough density so we had to we
had to have a mechanical shutter that
would close right after the exposure was
made but that was slow so we needed
another shutter in conjunction with that
they would close immediately after the
thing was over and not give us a
complete density but give us some and so
that was what we call her our fuse
shutter we'll get into that in a moment
tell us about some of the your
experiences and photographing atomic
explosions well there are they're quite
interesting the this this Kodak camera
that I mentioned to you I used a glass
disk 21 inches in diameter and it was
very precisely ground and so that it was
flat to it to better than a thousandth
of an inch when it would rotate and this
had to be loaded in the dark and so we
did it at night we loaded the camera at
night and then in order to recover it we
had to do it at night but the
helicopters that would take us away
bring his in take it away so we can't
operate at night so we have to go in
near dusk and we agreed we said with
enough cloth we can probably do this so
doc and I went out and recovered and we
we we got the it was it was a helicopter
operation we got off the ground and we
started to fly over the crater and the
pilot smelled gas so he cut the engine
right away what are you doing what do
you do here's the crater we just does so
he said well we're you know we we can't
fly anymore he got it come down I said
if you come down on that hole we're all
gonna die so he managed to get to the
edge of the of the island when he came
down and we we hollered he hollered
Mayday on the radio now Mayday as a
signal universally accepted everywhere
everybody listens to it stops finds out
what the trouble is
look I had any we talked ours said wheat
won so he didn't do it he good because
by the time we answered him again we
were below the line of sight and he
couldn't hear us so he that's where we
were stuck and we made our way into the
end of the bunker where we were
protected but it was dark there was no
electricity we figured that maybe we
could activate the telephone system but
we couldn't it was dark in there and we
couldn't see what we were doing
and I happened to lean against the wall
and there was a battlefield phone there
just for the heck of it I cranked it you
know on somebody said hello I said what
are you doing out there
said well you know we're in the bunker
we're stuck nobody's supposed to be
there while we are we're stuck we need
some help we just crashed in our
helicopter so then that started the
activity going and the pilot said to get
my friend Joel or whatever his name was
he knows what the problem isn't getting
to fly a piece out and he was helicopter
and so they did it took a you know it
took several hours to do all this it was
a very melodramatic thing they got out
there and they didn't have the right
tools so doc with his trusty screwdriver
said here let me do it so he replaced it
and he took off and came back that was
one of the hairy things we had a few
more like that
very interesting adventures I will say
that doc had a special little island on
one of these things all in himself and
he had a luau party every every three
weeks or so we'd all come with luau how
long a period of time was he out there
where and were you out in the South
Pacific doing this well months or how
well no it was this discovered a period
of several years well we'd all turn
eight we go to we'd go to any we talked
one time bikini another time and then
the Nevada Test Site another time we
started really even though we started
out at any we talked or a bikini that
was the Navy show the next move was any
we talked but before that started we had
an operation going out in Nevada
and that was still being designed on the
backs of envelopes when we got out there
so we we manned a big effort there where
we had trucks and after that was over we
said we then board ship and go out to
the any we talked thing so this covered
a period of a number of years but we
would be out there any one time for
maybe six weeks
then come back and dock didn't always go
he went whenever he got the opportunity
to go uses what he called his Pitt
electronic camera he got some startling
pictures because this this camera again
it was a special rep a tronic but he
used a very long focal length wings like
like a telescope so our camera stations
were usually something like 20 or 30
miles away or with this long telescope
he could get right on top of it so some
of the pictures you've seen of the cabs
that haven't quite exploded yet were
made of that camera okay let's let's
come back just for a little bit to the
non-military side of what you were
working on and I'd like you to talk a
bit about how the nighttime aerial
photography tube was readapted for for a
peacetime use yes that would be I think
the most spectacular one would would be
what we call the Sun flash and that got
its name because one of the photographic
studios in New York City was not not
excuse me I'll start on that one
completely so you can see that a little
bit more that frog keeps coming up the
Sun Flash evolved as a result of the
electronic aerial photography the aerial
photography was a it was called portable
because it was in an airplane weight
several tons and it it was basically a
lot of capacitors put together with one
flash tube and the flash tube was very
similar to this one that you can see
right in the back of me here a number of
photographic studios in New York each
year would go out to Arizona with a
bunch of models to model clothes for
things like Montgomery Ward catalog
and this one commercial illustrators was
not in on this they were not politically
in so they said is there there must be
some way that we can bring the Arizona
Sun into our studio so they called up
doc and doc said sure we can do that
well again you know we didn't know we
could but there's always a way and so I
got involved in that almost immediately
and the first thing I did was to find
out really what they needed so I took a
I took a unit down there that that
fortunately only weighed a half a ton
and and had a reflector on it
it was the tube was like what you see in
back of me but it was in this big
reflector when I got down to the studio
and they told me what the problem was
the first thing I did was to save paint
your walls white well in a photographic
studio that's the last thing you do you
don't want reflections from your walls
but in this case this would be as the
simulated sky so they agreed they'd do
it and then I took the reflector off the
off the lamp and got them to rig it up
on a tall pole and said now give me a
reflector for money or spotlights
that's about so big it has to be about
six or seven inches in diameter what's
that for is that well that's going to
look like the Sun that's going to
subtract they'll be the same sharpest so
the Sun is we put that in back of the
tube put this thing up on it on a pole
and I said now we need a model and the
the the the president and CEO of
commercial illustrators were sitting
there so I said you look like a good
model so you sit under this yo no I
don't photograph well what do you
photograph outside don't you sure well
this'll look like outside so we took a
picture of him sure enough they were all
flabbergasted when they saw it because
it looked just like sunlight and that's
how we got started so then we came back
I came back and reported my findings and
that's when we went to work and decided
that we would build a Sun flash unit for
them we didn't have it call at that time
named when we said that's a we came up
somebody came up with the idea Sun flash
and that's stuck and so we made it
pretty and the photographer's accepted
it and even today this this of course
occurred I'm trying to think what it did
happen probably in the mid 50's
something like that and even today that
Sun Flash is being used by a number of
studios not just on in New York but all
over
of course EG&G doesn't make them anymore
somebody else makes them but at least we
got them started okay I think to to
finish out I'd like you to talk about
your life after doc I know you started
up your own company and just to finish
out your your story here all right well
my my connection with Doc continued
because he had every summer he would
have a bunch of people come in where he
given lectures on high speed photography
and things like that so every year I
participated in those things and that
continued on and some of the films that
I had invented at EG&G for the AEC were
quite useful for our solar eclipses so I
became known as an eclipse chaser and I
had developed a film not for AEC but for
for NASA which had a wide exposure
letted latitude for use up on the moon
so that was ideal for Eclipse
photography so there was a where there
was a a particularly long eclipse that
was going to be a be seen over in Africa
and so I got a couple of friends to help
me out on that and one of them happened
to be my patent attorney and so he
agreed and he said yeah I'll go over and
help you but on the way back home I'd
like to have you help me on my project
sure I'll do that
so I said what's your project he says
I'm looking for the Loch Ness monster so
I got stuck on that one yeah tell it
tell us about that because I see your
name cropping up in Doc's notebook said
when he talks about Loch Ness well doc
had gotten involved in this project
before I did but he said you're not
gonna use my name so now I'll warn you
some equipment and which he did he had
developed some equipment for the
National Geographic for underwater work
and he said this ought to this ought to
do for you so he gave it to Bob Ryan's
to use and Bob just couldn't get him to
come over there he doesn't want to have
anything to do with it but he had
trapped me obviously and so I got to
work with Bob on that and we developed
up a system each year we go over it
would be better we'd we finally
connected sonars with it and computers
and everything else and we got some
pretty good pictures in 1975 and talked
heard about it
so he said hey what's what's this that I
hear about your pictures from Loch NESA
whoa oh you you wouldn't be interested
in those dr. well what do they like oh
you don't want to see the wall can I
come out look at him
oh sure if you want so he and gene moon
he came out and he looked at him he said
it's a too late to join the team so so
he got he was publicly hooked at that
time and so we went over a number of
times and the last big episode we
decided we needed an underwater
photographer and somebody came up with
it we were thinking of you know
underwater robots and things like that
but we couldn't get our hands on those
we didn't any money as a matter of fact
the our team consisted of X MIT guys
that were used to scrounging you know we
go down oh hey that's a good piece of
equipment who owns that we talked the
guy into joining the team he bring it
over and so
somebody we couldn't find anybody at MIT
that was really working on underwater
robots at that time so somebody came up
with the idea of using dolphins and that
was a red hot idea
so we dived into that one and I
contacted the Navy to see what they were
doing because I knew they were using
dolphins for some purpose and said what
what kind of harnesses do you use well
they wouldn't tell us too much but they
sent us something they said here's a
harness that we're using we looked at it
and it was terrible it was looked like
spaghetti if you put it if you put the
harness on the dolphin he couldn't ever
get out of it
there was a sure death trap so he said
we can't use that so we developed our
own harness called a voluntary harness
where the dolphin would swim into this
thing on its own and swim out anytime I
wanted and we'd strapped the equipment
onto it a camera on one side a light
source on the other and that looked fine
and we trained the Dolphins down in
Florida and it's amazing what you can do
with a dolphin
the the trainer knew exactly how to how
to train them and explained to the
dolphin somehow or another through his
hand signals that we wanted the Dolphins
to take pictures of objects a certain
size so they got the idea well we're
that size so they were taking pictures
of each other so we had a killing with
that idea and they were also taking
pictures they'd come up every now and
then get a picture of us on land but we
did have them we got them trained so
that they would go underwater
look for these things and we figured
that we didn't know what the so-called
monster would do we knew they weren't
monsters but we didn't know what they
were and so we said we'd better have
we've got to use two dolphins one on to
ride shotgun for the other in case it
got into trouble then the third way the
second one could know they Iran and
scare the creature off as long as we had
two dolphins put cameras on each one so
we knew with it with a voluntary harness
we had a very good chance of losing our
equipment if they got tired of it or
something they'd just drop it so we
decided to train them to retrieve our
equip
when they dropped it and we selected
what we thought was the smartest dolphin
to wear the harness and the other one we
said well you you'll be the retriever
well it turned out the one that we
selected as a retriever was the smart
one
because when she she dolphins work only
for food they don't work for love or
anything else their paycheck is a fish
so when she saw the other dolphin with a
harness on
she knew heard her job was to retrieve
it so she poked the other dolphin and
the rhibs it would drop the harness she
get on get it get her fish they're
crafty creatures so we got a well
trained and the camera equipment was
highly sophisticated at that point we
had as I say our own sonar and the
course that Dolphin uses sonar and it
did not interfere with a dolphin sonar
except when they we tried to put the
harness on and it often didn't like it
so we knew that we couldn't turn the
sonar on until the dolphin was already
in the harness
so he had a little magnetic switch in
the thing and when the dolphin when the
dolphin had the harness on we'd reached
out of the magnet and turn it on but the
dolphin knew that so before we got a
chance to do it it would swim away so we
built a little automatic pressure switch
so then when the dolphin swam down about
15 feet the thing would come on and then
it would get his pictures and now when
you go to a dolphin show and you see
these stunts after the stunt has been
performed the trainer whistles a loud
whistle and that's the signal to the
dolphin to come up and get his paycheck
so we had to build one of these whistles
into the camera and after about 15
pictures then the whistle would go off
and the dolphin would come up get his
paycheck and then get back down again
and so we knew that you know this was
gonna be it and so we we were delayed
some six weeks because of our training
effort so here was everybody over
lochness waiting for us and we weren't
there yet we finally got the Dolphins
ready to fly over
and when you transport it often it's a
it's a tremendous ordeal for a dolphin
but these dolphins have been transported
and a number of times before so they
knew what what it was do you have to you
have to suspend him and a harness you
have to coat him with lanolin and keep
massaging him all the time and squirt
water on him and we reactivated the hull
aquarium in Boston that was one that was
destroyed during one of the hurricanes
we reactivated it so we could put her
dolphin there well you know rest up
before he went over the ocean and the
dolphin had been there about two days
when I died so that was the end of that
because we were known from him we tried
to give it from the press but he
couldn't do it
so we were known as the people who
murdered the dolphins so that end of
that project and we've never been able
to reactivate it again but that would
have been the perfect thing well we kept
going over to Loch Ness trying things
out in fact the last expedition the doc
was on before he died was over Loch Ness
he had had a serious problem an
operation about a year before that but
he and before that he had committed
himself to give a lecture over in
Scotland for England I guess it was
England at one of the museums and so
Esther tried to keep him from doing it
but I said no I'm gonna do this said
I've spent all this time preparing the
lecture please let me do it they so we
took advantage of this time that he was
over that's it okay we'll mount an
expedition when you're through come on
up and we'll do something so that's the
way I work out and of course we didn't
get anything on that expedition either
but he had a chance to get over there
and try it and it wasn't many months
after that in January that was when he
died so he died with his boots on doing
the things he loved so what's your
verdict isn't is Nessie down there well
there's something there there's no
question about it we've got enough data
to know that there's something there we
can't tell you how many they are or what
they are well we know enough to know
that they also have a sonar there
we were very very fortunate we tried to
scan the spectrum to see if they did
have sonar we never caught it but one
time we happened to catch one on our
sonar down about 300 feet and it
detected our sonar and so it gave out a
burst of its own to see where we are and
swam off we never caught it again so at
least we we did see it sonar so here it
is over there I it's not a monster
obviously everybody has an idea to drag
on the breathes fire eats people and
what it doesn't do that apparently it's
very very shy otherwise it'd be seen
much more often and if I had to describe
what it was I'd say it was something
like a giraffe without any legs that's
about the size of it so it's not
gigantic you know maybe eight or ten
feet long with a long neck and how many
there are I don't know maybe they're
dying out in you can't have one survive
as long as this the reports have been
coming in for 1,400 years so it had to
be a family of mice I'm sorry and you
can't have a family smaller than 20
otherwise they died all due to
inbreeding maybe that's the problem
maybe it was a colony of 20 and they've
died out we don't know we just don't
know okay serious there anything else
you want it I've gone through my
questions is there anything else you
wanted to talk about it I don't think so
jim has a question
okay that's right it didn't really come
up until sort of after after the thing
all right okay the the interesting
question is what is e G and G's and by
the way let me let me preface this thing
by saying that when when the Atomic
Energy Commission was formed and they
selected us as a prime contractor we
were still at MIT we were a partnership
at that time but we had grown to about
from five of us we had grown to about
maybe 40 or 50 and the AEC demanded that
we have our own guards
well MIT didn't take kindly to that so
they said you better you better leave
but we were in MIT up until that time so
then we decided that we better
incorporate because the AEC couldn't
have a partnership as a prime contractor
so we were edgerton germeshausen and
grier incorporated for a couple of years
until people couldn't stumble over the
name anymore so we shortened at the EG&G
and that was about 19 oh I guess
probably 48 49
and we are our basic our basic interest
prior to the war was electronic flash
and high-speed motion pictures we did
consulting work but after the war we
decided that we'd better we better do
something else and it turned out that
herb Grier was part of the Manhattan
Project so this looked like an
interesting thing that we might be able
to do and so we turned out to be
responsible for the triggering system
for the a-bomb as the later a bombs so
we came up with the with the triggering
system that's one of the things we did
it looked like we were the ones to take
over for the timing and firing because
Los Alamos proved that they couldn't do
it when they as the bikini test when
when their signals didn't come out right
so we did that and as I mentioned to you
before we in talking with the embryo AEC
people we convinced them that we could
also do the scientific photography and
the reason for this photography was not
documentation but rather to determine
what the efficiency of an explosion was
because one of the easiest ways that you
that that you can increase the
efficiency is rather increase the
stockpile is to increase the efficiency
of the explosion and we developed a
system whereby by measuring the diameter
of the fireball at a given time and
plotting the curve we could determine
very precisely what the efficiency was
prior to that the only way they had of
knowing was through radio chemistry so
this was one of the things that we we
concentrated on so all the photography
basically was for that purpose was for
measuring the efficiency and each time
we would find out what the efficiency
was and they'd say well let's try this
next measure to get and so we went from
less than a percent efficiency of
Nagasaki Hiroshima explosions up to you
know doubling tripling quadrupling and
so on the stockpile just by increasing
the efficiency and I'm not about to tell
you what it is now but it's pretty high
and so our work in that end was was
focused on how to increase the
efficiency and how to measure it we did
since we had to build a lot of equipment
to do these things it became obvious
that these instruments could be used
commercially so we developed an eg ng a
commercial arm that would produce these
instruments for things other than the
AEC or the military and we came up with
new oscilloscopes we came up with new
light measuring equipment I came up with
a sensitometer and a lot of things like
this we developed new cameras new light
sources underwater photography a a new
business was created as a result of our
underwater photography and that was Sam
Raymond with his benthos equipment and
there are a number of there are a number
of things like this that got started now
I probably would have continued on with
EG&G but since they were getting out of
the photographic end of things and that
was my specialty because I'd worked on
that Fred Barstow and I I had to buy
back the patents that EG&G had and we
decided to buy those back and start
selling this film commercially you know
I did it didn't wouldn't have a wide use
but scientifically it had a had a good
use and unfortunately and during this
time my son was killed so I got I got
bypassed on that and decided to go into
something that would have saved his life
if we had it on the roads and so that's
my business now called bright line it's
a new highway marketing system but a G &
G has has continued on there there I
understand now that they're getting out
of the Defense Department business
altogether but up until the last few
years that was their major source of in
come not a bombs obviously because I was
still part of it but a very small part
of it and herb Greer had a had a bad
conscious problem so he finally decided
he didn't want to have anything to do
with atom bombs anymore and so he was
the only one in the whole group that
really felt morose about it I guess
I don't think Barney O'Keeffe felt that
way although he told people he did he
didn't really because he knew he knew
what the purpose was and if we didn't do
it the Japanese the German somebody
would do it and we had to keep in the
fourth on the forefront because this was
this was a sort of weapon that the
United States should have control over
not to use it in discriminately but to
make sure nobody else used it but to do
this we had to make sure that we had a
decent stockpile because we knew the
Russians were building up their
stockpile he did it the same way so I
don't think any of us had a had a
conscious problem that way although that
wasn't our primary business is this more
or less what you had in mind Jim
okay docks main memory should be his way
that he gets people interested in
experiments and learning he turns out to
be an excellent teacher in a way that
other people hadn't never thought of and
that was to get the students involved
with her hands early in experiments and
he believed that there was no such thing
as a failure that you always learned
something if you didn't learn anything
else well that that way isn't the way to
do it
you got to do it some other way so
that's his legacy really how did how to
teach people and he created a new method
of doing it and I think that's going to
become more obvious as time goes on and
I think this is going to be felt in the
in strobe Ali Kim Vandiver has taken
over and he's an ideal guy to do this
because I think he feels the same way